[Music]
Yonsei clint eastwood how are you yes
I'm fine darling oh good to see you
thank you
we've never met I'm a big fan and I just
want to say I'm a big fan thank you for
the headset yeah you gave me a few years
ago oh you're welcome
I didn't know I did but you know
something that's been somebody your
company sent it under your name oh great
great yeah no I told them to um so um
did you have a script for me no I don't
I just wanted to say hi yeah you're
getting me jealous because I saw you
gave smarty a script yeah no I actually
it's more important actually I want to
take a picture from MySpace do you mind
if I get a picture with you can somebody
take this Oh Steven Spielberg actually
yeah can I get Steven yeah what's that
right there
sorry I mean I'm sure yeah yeah he's
Jesus right make sure we're both in
Steven
that's right can I just see it make it
more even on both sides look at that
what do you think is feeling compose yes
that's better it's good oh thanks so
much
that's exciting all right look at us oh
not bad right yeah yeah